- Boston Consulting
Group is suing the mean
the meme stock company, GameStop,
for 30 million U.S. dollars
in unpaid consulting fees.
Wow, what's going on here?
I can promise you this whole
story is complete craziness.
This is what I wanna to
talk about with you today.
So where come here on
and another Coffee Break,
here on my channel, where I
try to help become successful
in the first years of your career.
The reason I wanna talk about
the story is that first,
I think it's quite juicy,
it's quite interesting
what is happening here.
But second, it's also very
insightful to better understand
how big consulting firms,
like Boston Consulting Group,
actually work,
and what type of projects
they do for their clients.
And so for this video,
now I did some Firm Learning
detective work for you,
because I got hold on some court documents
that Boston Consulting
Group filed to sue GameStop.
And these core documents
are quite interesting.
Indeed. Lots of very juicy details
on what they're actually
doing for GameStop.
So let's look into them in a moment.
Before they let me just
to read out this statement
that GameStop gave to Financial Times,
as a response to what BCG is doing.
And GameStop is saying,
"We do not believe it is in our
stockholders' best interests
"to pay the tens of millions of dollars
"sought by Boston Consulting Group,
"especially given their
seemingly meager impact
"on the company's bottom line.
"We will fight this suit,
"and are proud that
GameStop no longer utilizes
"the likes of BCG for any services."
Ah, that's a really heavy tobacco here.
I just wanna make it really
clear that, of course,
all of this document here is
written from the prospective
of Boston Consulting Group.
So I have of course, no insider knowledge
into any of this at all.
I have no idea whether what
Boston Consulting Group
is claiming, is alleging
here in the document,
is true or not, but let's
go into it, nevertheless.
So these are the court
filings that I found,
as you can see, this is with
Boston Consulting Group,
as a plaintiff, and GameStop
Corporation as a defendant.
And this was apparently
filed on the 22nd of March.
Obviously, I'm no legal professional,
so anything I say from legal perspectives,
is not maybe accurate.
Just let me know in the comments.
I'm happy to learn from you to
just understand this better.
What I wanna do is really
go over this with you,
and I already read this in advance,
and just provided some highlights,
some yellow highlights of the parts
I feel like are most relevant,
and most interesting.
So let's look into it.
So what does BCG want?
Where they're claiming that
there are, from GameStop side,
bad faith refusal to pay
fees out to BCG, right?
They're describing a bit the
situation of the company.
So here,
"By 2019, GameStop was on live support,
"really not doing well, was
reporting a net operating loss
"of almost $800 million of 2018,
"and was one of the most
heavily shorted stocks,
"relative to its float."
So this is maybe what some of you know,
If you followed the whole
GameStop story last year,
how it became a meme stock.
And so from all of this,
GameStop then engaged BCG in 2019
to evaluate its operations,
and develop solutions
that would enable a
corporate transformation.
So, apparently there was a target set
of generating an additional
200 million or more in profit,
per year, going forward,
that BCG wanted to the
deliver to the client.
And the idea of course,
why it might make sense for
a company to pay even a fee
of let's say 30 million U.S. dollar,
which is what they're
fighting here apparently,
in court about, is that, of course,
if you are able to improve
profits, of course,
this is not a one-off right?
This will be on a recurring basis.
So if you are able to increase
the profit by $200 million
on a recurring basis,
it's quite easy to
justify the business case
of paying as a one off, right, $30 million
in consulting fees.
So that's of course a big difference.
The fees are only a one off,
but the profit, the savings,
are recurring
which is why the business case
often then does make sense.
"BCG provided support to
GameStop in connection
"with 10 different workstreams,
"spread across a broad
range of business areas
"and opportunities."
And I think this is now a
bit more interesting also,
going into how consulting firms work.
So if you are a consulting firm,
and you set up such a big
transformation program,
often it will be divided
into different pieces,
and the different names for that here,
workstream is one of them.
Other firms sometimes
also call it modules.
10 different workstreams
is quite a significant
transformation program.
That's really big, right?
I mean, imagine managing
10 big independent topics
next to each other.
On smaller programs,
sometimes it's the case
that it's only one project
team working on it.
And then maybe there's the project lead,
and then two, three,
four, five associates.
And then each of the
associates is responsible
for one of the workstreams.
But in a larger program,
and I would assume, I
don't know of course,
but I would assume that
this is what happened here,
often each individual workstream
is being worked on by an
independent project team,
or at least the most
important workstreams,
are being worked on by
independent project teams.
And then there's often one
project team on top of all of it,
coordinating it all, serving as a PMO,
is often call project management office.
Then it also goes on saying,
"BCG would be compensated
"on the greater of a fixed fee,
"or a variable fee,
"based upon projected
profit improvements."
So the fee was not predetermined or kept.
And this, I think was also is
quite something noteworthy,
because sometimes there's this
prejudgement against consultants,
where people say that, oh, you know,
the consultants they just
create these fancy strategies,
and then they get a fixed fee for that.
And then they just leave.
And so the fear is not
really success based.
But that's not always the case.
Rather often, actually,
consulting firms do have
some performance components
in their fees.
And this is here now really
also describing how this works
right?
And they now will start
together, of course,
with the client, start ideating,
creating all types of measures,
all types of ideas, for initiatives,
then could potentially
to profit improvements.
And then often you say, or
how this works is often,
that then the consulting firm
comes in and says, well, okay,
let's do here performance based program.
As soon as we have a measure
where your controller,
where your client,
where your controller says that
yes, this measure is viable,
then I get paid for that, right?
And this is this idea of projections,
of anticipated profit improvements.
And so now here, it goes on explaining why
this was the type of
agreement that was made,
"To protect BCG from additional factors,
"such as GameStop's execution risk."
And this of course,
where you could say now,
that these types of
agreements, maybe sometimes,
are a little bit sneaky,
because it's very easy, right,
to come up with an idea and
have a controller, you know,
there's a business case behind it,
or maybe an executive decision
to them bring it live.
But then often of course, in the execution
is where many of these things go wrong.
Of course there is them.
And often these measures fail, right,
and are not really being
executed rightfully.
And this of course here is where BCG says,
well, that's not my problem.
That's your problem, right,
if you are not able to execute
them, I will still get paid.
And so now you can argue
whether that's fair or not.
But at least I think it's
fair to say that of course,
here that two very competent actors,
were negotiating this,
and we're agreeing that this is fine.
And then this is what the
parties agreed in the end.
But I think also,
if you read a statement like
the statement I just quoted you
from GameStop, in the beginning,
where they were saying
that actually the work
did not lead to of profit
improvements in the end,
at least this is what
GameStop was claiming
in the statement.
There you see the problem with
agreements like that, right?
Because again, here BCG wants to get paid
based on projections.
And GameStop is saying, well,
thank you for these projections.
But in the end, these
things didn't realize,
didn't realize in the bottom line.
This seems to be the main conflict,
or at least part of the conflict
that these parties are having.
Just me judging based on all
the statements here, right?
I think this is quite interesting
because here in the filings,
BCG talks about the workstreams
that they were working on.
So I think this is an insight
that probably don't
get that all that often
from other content.
And you can see that here,
there are 10 workstreams going on.
I just highlighted some yellow ones,
some very typical ones.
If we just top, and
also also read the text
and all the other ones.
So here first,
"Org efficiency and effectiveness,
"to unlock both costs and
operational improvement
"through a combination
of organization levers,
"improved spans of control,
"more effective reporting structures,
"redesigning roles and
responsibilities among others."
And I mean, frankly, this
usually is just, you know,
nice speak for saying
they want to cut costs,
and the overhead of GameStop.
So if we read this right,
so improved spans of control
means that one manager is
now responsible potentially
for more people than before.
And by that you might be able to take out
some middle management
roles, and similar things,
of course is when you talk
about redesigned roles and
responsibilities, among others.
Category performance improvements.
So here, it looks like
they're looking into just
different business areas,
working together with the vendors
to potentially release additional
cost improvements here,
getting better prices,
negotiating with them.
So these are often procurement
related initiatives.
Indirect procurement,
this of course also an
procurement initiative.
So usually you'll think
about direct procurement,
and indirect procurement.
So direct procurement is everything
that goes into the product.
So the manufacturing context that might be
for instance, the steel that you use
to really build the product or here.
in such a retail component, of course,
that would be be the
merchandise that they purchase.
Indirect procurement are all
the other cost that you have,
with the exception of personnel, right?
So not personnel,
but all the other cost positions
that are not really directly
related to the product.
So this could be your utilities.
This could be your rent,
the rent that you pay.
In global enterprise,
these are often global
footprint decisions,
for the company, right?
So which markets am I active in?
How is my organization distributed?
Where do I have offices?
Is there any potential maybe,
just to close down complete countries,
where I'm just losing money,
not making any profit at all,
maybe just to close down
some production facilities,
if I have any closed down,
maybe some headquarters
administrative offices,
sales offices that I have.
And here, let's look how
just additional explanations
on how this whole variable
compensation component
was supposed to be built,
and was supposed to be paid.
And they were supposed to hold
some regular sessions together,
with the GameStop team,
and the BCG team,
where the idea was that
they look together,
at all these numbers, at all these facts,
all these initiatives that they created.
And then they just wanted to
ideally form a joint opinion
or what the status is.
And then based on this
view, then of course,
also proceed with all the invoicing.
And they called these
meetings, thermometer meetings.
I think that's also an interesting name.
And all these projected profits
were supposed to be calculated
against agreed upon baselines,
not actual profits realized.
This whole idea of building baselines
is also an important one,
because this is often also especially,
in the beginning of these
transformation programs,
something that
at least the one associate
will often be concerned with.
And here, the idea really is that
that this person often just tries
to develop different scenarios.
So, tries to develop a scenario,
what would happen if
nothing would happen, right?
So if no measure would be taken,
if just business continues as usual,
how does maybe then the situation
of the company look like
in one year from now?
And this is then the baseline.
And then against this baseline,
you the measure all the
financial improvements.
And then of course, based on that,
you can also develop scenarios,
so based on the effect
of all the measures,
sometimes of course the
baselines are not constant,
but deteriorating, right?
So imagine a company
where profits were down,
year over year, over year.
Of course us on this baseline
will go into the negative
for the next year, right?
So what you will say is
that if we do nothing,
next year profits will be,
let's say just a random number,
a hundred million less
than last year, right?
And now of course, any profit improvement
you can calculate on top of this baseline.
But what this also means is
that even though, if you have,
or if you stand or realize 100 million
in initiatives and profit
improvement initiatives,
this would just leave
the company's bottom line
just with no change, right?
Just with the zero data
compared to the last year,
because you're not necessarily measuring
against the last year,
but you're measuring against
the deteriorating baseline.
And of course this isn't
something that maybe
not always managers really realize,
if they put this together
with with the help of
these consulting firms.
And then of course they expect big jumps,
big increases in profit.
And then of course you'll often have
these difficult situations,
where the consulting firms claim, oh,
you know, realize like all
these great profit improvements,
but then the company's just
looking at the bottom line,
comparing one year with the other,
seeing there's actually no change at all,
and then just wondering what
exactly happened here, right,
what the work of the
consulting firm has brought us.
I think this logic of
measuring against the baseline
is not wrong, but of course
not always easy to communicate
in these dispute type of situations.
So you can see that, you
know, what is, I mean,
what is BCG claiming that GameStop failed,
and refuse to pay BCG, that if they paid,
they they paid late, that here,
the CFO demanded all types
of unsupported reductions
to BCG fees,
that they just ceased to attend
these thermometer meetings.
I mean, that's of course also a strategy.
If you just don't attend
these meetings anymore,
then BCG doesn't have any
bases of going to you,
and trying to charge you
for these cost improvements.
That's apparently what
they tried to do here.
This, this is what BCG claims
again, no idea, of course,
whether this is correct or not.
And here they're just saying, you know,
unpaid fees of approximately 30 millions.
This is what they want to have.
And the interesting thing
they're also saying,
"The exact amount of
the very fees own to BCG
"is undetermined at this time,
"due to GameStop's refusal
to hold thermometer meetings,
"or otherwise furnish the data necessary
"to determine certain
profit improvements."
That's exactly the problem, right?
So if you just stop attending this meeting
then of course you don't
have any issues here.
So that's really the gist
of what's happening here.
I must say, when I read all this
I did find this to be quite interesting.
I hope you feel the very same way.
So now let me know in the comments
it's all of this surprising to you?
Did you already know
that this is how these firms operate?
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please set the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to stay
up to date on my content.
My name is Heinrich, with weekly
videos here on my channel.
Big, big, thanks to the
members of Firm Learning,
for you support, much appreciated.
See again next week, until
then, all the best to you,
and bye bye.